- You will have two shots.
- Justin Trudeau reçoit une dose
de rappel contre la COVID
et une autre contre
la grippe saononnière.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- La vaccination contre
la grippe, c'est une bonne idée.
On sququque c'est un grand défi
cette saison-ci.
- Le premier ministre veut
donner l'exemple pour tenter
peut-être de limiter les dégâts
nsnsns le secteur de la santé.
C'est qu'après la COVID,
une véritable collection de
virus frappe la population.
CAROLINE QUACH, microbiologiste
pédiatre, Hôpital Sainte-Justine
- Habituellement, t'sais,
ils se passent le témoin
un après l'autre, mais là,
ils ont décidé de tous courir
en même temps, donc on a du VRS.
On commence à avoir
de l'influenza,
on a du parainfluenza.
- Suivez-moi, s'il vous plaît.
- Un cocktail potentiellement
explosif, assez pour que
le CIUSSS du Nord-de-l'Île-de-
Montréal déplace les équipes
de vaccination près du domicile
des plus vulnérables.
AMÉLIE THIFFAULT, coordo. vacc.
CIUSSS Nord-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
- On sait que l'influenza
va revenir probablement plus
forte que les autres années,
fait que c'est d'emblée
pour protéger les gens,
pour éviter les complications,
pour éviter les hospitalisations
reliées à ça.
- Les urgences viv
des débordements sans précédent
alors que la grippe saisonnière
frappe un mois plus tôt
qu'à l'habitude.
- Non, c'est la première fois.
- Lucien Rainville reçoit
le vaccin contre la grippe
pour la première fois.
LUCIEN RAINVILLE, résident,
Demeures Sainte-Croix
- Rendu à 86 ans, ça magane
plus qu'à 30 ans, hein!
C'est ça!
- Prenez une grande respiration.
- Environ 40 % des personnes
âgées ont été vaccinées.
Ce n'est que la moitié de
l'objectif final au Québec.
- J'ai changé d'idée deux fois,
trois fouiuiuiuiui, oui!
Et puis là, j'ai décidé
de le faire.
- Vous êtes nerveuse?
- Une bonne idée, selon
letététététés. Les aînés
et les enfants sont plus
vulnérables face à la souche
dominante de la grippe,
cette année. Avec les masquesa ,
l'immunité collective a diminué
pendant la pandémie.
- Notre immunité n'a pas été
stimulée, ce qui fait que
nos anticorps, ils ne sont pas
présents. Alors, quand
on rencontre le virus,
bien, on est infectés.
- Ici Davide Gen
Radio-Canada, Montréal.